how are you doing today sir
i'm doing well steve uh i'm going to
start with i always
you're you're obviously fantastic in
these movies
i'm just going to say i really enjoy
your work in these things and uh
you're making me look away from the
screen at least a few times
and well i don't know keep your eyes
riveted to it you know
have you ever pulled federal aside and
been like you know you guys come up with
some pretty messed up stuff right
well yeah do i i have
i have said to uh at one point i said
what's going on
in your mind i mean you sick son of a
gun
yeah but uh but i've i've gotten tuned
into it you know
they've taken me along with them i've
gotten as
i've gotten as depraved as they are
um when you made the first movie uh
obviously there was no way of predicting
it was going to be this huge hit
what was your like optimistic goal when
making the first film in terms of box
office and
how it would be received well i i i mean
i can honestly say i had no box office
expectations
at all i don't uh i i you know i i don't
really
think in in those terms i don't because
i don't know enough about it you hope
for success i i mean i'll say god i hope
it's a hit
you know uh for sure uh i think that
when it played at south by southwest um
i think that was an indication that that
it was going to be
good that it was uh there was buzz on it
and then and then
and i saw the picture and i thought this
is a good picture my aspirations from
the beginning
were uh make a really good movie
make it and play do your job the best
you can play your character as honestly
and as um you know as as as
as authentically uh as you possibly can
and the rest will take care of itself
that was my such was my thinking i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
making
movies um what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of don't breathe two
or even the first one i'm not sure what
would surprise them i mean it's a
painstaking process
it is there's a certain amount of
uh improvisation uh
that that that goes on if not everything
is completely plotted out
um that the best laid plans of uh
directors
can be um can kind of go out the window
when when they say action and uh you
know
stuff just you know the first starts
flying as
as it were uh but i i maybe they'd be
surprised at how
um just how professional and
grown up um madeleine grace was
during this i mean she and also i guess
i would say
that you know a film set we're making
this horrific film
you know the world of this film is dark
and
everything actually when you're making
the movie it's all
everything is very very you know sedate
and quiet and
normal when when the cameras are not
rolling i i'd say you know
but i don't know that you can really
surprise people anymore
there's been so much behind the scenes
and every a lot of the magic of making
films
has been uh i think has been kind of
exposed
in a way which is not to say that people
still don't love the movies because they
do
i think you're totally true that the
magic of the behind the scenes is all
out there
but i found that almost on every
production or every movie that i talk to
people about
there's always something that is unusual
to that one production
or something that people would just not
expect you know
you know i guess on this one i would say
is that you know we although
of course this takes place in detroit
and and
and for both movies there is a real
location in detroit which
where we've gone to do exterior work
both of these houses were built
you know one in budapest hungary and one
in
um in serbia in uh belgrade
and so you know here we are making a
film that's taking place in the
you know the the outskirts of uh uh the
no man's land of detroit actually where
you know we're in eastern europe for
both of
them yeah that definitely people i think
are always amazed about
these films get put together or you'll
shoot something in one sequence
in south africa and the other sequence
was in los angeles
that's been the history of the movies
you know
forever it's always been i mean i always
love hearing you know sergio leone when
he was finishing
once upon a time in america he had to
import red dirt from spain to hollywood
to kind of match
it's like really cool anyway absolutely
absolutely um do you enjoy playing
someone that it has such a
broken moral compass yeah
i do i enjoy enjoy exploring uh
that i mean it it's uh it gives you a
lot to
kind of work with as you try to take the
you know you look down at the jagged
pieces of your life and you try to
try to fit them together in some way or
you don't do that and you try to carry
on as a broken mechanism
it seems to me and uh that that's
that's fascinating stuff to do
as an actor it's not the most it's not
the only fascinating thing or possibly
even the most fascinating thing
but it's pretty damn fascinating uh
fede told me that when you step on set
uh you sort of disappear and your
character
emerges until you leave set is that
pretty much how you operate on
on all the things you've done or is it
only on particular projects
it's um it's more so on some projects
than on other but
essentially it it's it's a much simpler
way to operate
you know uh than it is i i kind of stick
to my
it's easier or it's simpler on a project
like this
because he's such an isolated character
that
it's really easy for me just to retreat
into my own self you know
uh there are other projects on which i
may play someone more gregarious and
that may entail me being a lot more
public uh
on the set because that that because uh
because that helps or i like to
and then there may be things where it
just doesn't operate at all i mean it's
possible
i think but you also you always need to
keep the amber of the character kind of
you know uh glowing it seems to me
and whatever whatever is required you do
this long enough you learn to kind of
modulate you just have sort of an
internal thing that tells you how much
how how deep you need to be in
at any one particular moment completely
um
how much are you enjoying or how much do
you want to put yourself
in the fight sequences and how much are
you sort of like i have a stunt person
and i'm going to let them help me i want
the sequence to come out the best that
it possibly can
and uh traditionally that has certainly
met me doing an awful lot of the stuff
myself because there's
you can't trade that you know that
that's important stuff
but there are things that it really does
pay
to have someone do for you
for whatever reason usually it would
have to do with
a fall that you know it just requires
technique
that i know i may think that
i have and maybe i did have at one point
but maybe maybe i don't quite have it
anymore or
is it really worth taking taking that
risk you know
uh and that's what these guys are for
there's always an aspect not only do i
play
my role i am also the steward
of my role the custodian of my role
and what does that mean it means that i
have to do everything i can to make sure
that the role comes first the character
comes first the character is played
to the best that it can be played and
sometimes that requires the cooperation
the assistance the intervention of other
people
including stunt people before i run out
of time with you
i am obviously a huge fan of james
cameron and
avatar uh i love the way that he
basically pushes technology forward in
all of his movies in a way that
no one sees coming can you sort of talk
about what it's like collaborating with
him
on these upcoming films and maybe how
how he's pushing
technology again yeah he's definitely
pushing it
big time on this one and i'm not i'm not
giving away any trade secrets to say
that
but i remember working on a sequence
with him which
he which was had there was a scale an
issue of scale
going on okay and
and it was defeating it was just it
sort of brought everything to kind of a
halt
there was a problem that no one else
recognized except him
at the moment and so he had to come up
with a solution anyway we basically shut
down
or started working on something else
because yeah the next day he came to me
kind of you know real excited and said i
figured out the algorithm
to do this and and he he stated this
algorithm
and i'm looking at him thinking what the
hell are you talking about i have no
idea
even what you're talking about but he
did he he he
he he created a problem because he
because he want he
there was a problem because he wanted a
scene something to happen
and then he solved it he's been doing
that for his entire career
and it's really it's pretty cool pretty
amazing if you don't mind me asking and
i don't want to get you in any trouble
but what was it like reading those
scripts for the first time
what what did you take away from i don't
know if you've read all four at the same
time or just one of them
but could you sort of talk about that
when i finished the last script
i i was uh weeping i just thought it was
so
beautiful yeah the the final script
because
because he told he's he's telling a
great great story
an original story a beautiful beautiful
story
and uh um i i was just incredibly
um you know moved by it and i hope and i
trust and believe
that audiences will be too because one
of the things that he does really really
well
is he takes he moves it from the page to
the stage in a
very very way in a way
that that you is very literal you know
what i mean you you really see it what
you what just what you read is what you
get
from him i think you know and more and
more in fact so
that's all i'd say a year from now we'll
start to be talking about
that at great length for today it's all
it's about you know a
show i love equally which is don't
breathe for sure 100
i will stop there and i'm just going to
say congrats on this and i cannot wait
to talk to you again down the road for
this other thing
for sure